okay so the next session is about how to
manage your CEO so let me ask you how
many people hands up if you're an
employee and not the CEO excellent so
hopefully you'll be able to take away
some tangible lessons and tips that you
can take to rein those crazy people in
who can empathize with this meme hands
up yeah knowing how to handle the
prioritization of what to build in your
product when you have so many competing
opinions stakeholders self-interest
not to mention important people like
your CEO or CFO s very strong views
maybe on the type of color of green for
example so how do you avoid opinion
based product prioritization well this
was an interest of mine so a few months
ago I interviewed about 15 to 20 of our
top developers I interviewed Google
engineers Google product managers
directors of growth and like you know
tried to tease out of them how did they
approach this problem and you know what
struck me was there were two key
characteristics the first is that
successful developers rely on data to
make a call on what to experiment on
first and what to build and the second
really important factor was that they
had imbued this culture of data and
sharing of information throughout their
organization so to add color and context
to this discussion in a few minutes I'll
be inviting on stage both one tap and
2017 app of the year winner memorize to
share with us their experience
is on raining in their crazy CEOs I know
one of them is there laughing he's not
that crazy so let's get started with
with prioritization and just a note the
models and suggestions that we make here
today are just some of the best
practices that you know you can use so
they're not the only ones you can use
but hopefully you'll be able to take
away some key nuggets of gold right so
just a few seconds ago
many of you had put up your hands to say
that prioritization was hard but it can
be made easier with data
thank you for reconfirming so over the
last month I've worked with the one tap
team to test out a model that Google
used internally for deciding how to
prioritize what we build we use this
model on a low YouTube Gmail and we
actually have an internal growth team
who gets seconded out to our different
products so I harnessed that team and we
worked with one tap now again this is
not the only way to do it
bear with me but if it gives you a
different perspective this is a good
thing now before I introduce John on
stage let me just give you a brief
overview of this Google model
okay so as you can see it's pretty
simple it looks pretty simple it's made
up of four components the Northstar
metric user flows a growth model and a
spreadsheet because let's face it what
database model would be complete without
a spreadsheet
now the model serves to help you uncover
opportunities and more importantly it
serves as a common communication tool
for your whole company to talk about
growth products and prioritization so to
kick off and go deeper on this the first
one I mentioned was the North Star
metric now listening to Antony rebo's
talk about behavioral design it's
struck me that we were talking about the
same thing which is it's that key
engagement user metric now the way that
we define a Northstar metric is that it
encapsulates everything that you do in
your app and it captures all the value
that you're providing to a user so as an
example if anyone here is staying at
Airbnb this week it would be nights
booked for whatsapp it would be messages
sent so again the purpose is to create a
shared goal across all of your different
divisions in your company
so they're all going for the same goal
the next element is mapping the user
flows as anyone here maps their user
flows a few of you good okay so this
might be familiar to you the way that we
approach it is that essentially we
define user flows as a visual
representation of your user journeys
throughout your app across acquisitions
engagement conversion or retention and
that closed from sources of acquisition
critical user journeys you drill down on
some important aspects
perhaps your engagement activities and
your retention activities now I can see
you taking photos madly the next bits
gonna really mess it up take your photo
now once you've mapped this out and I
quite like the color coding it helps me
visualize it better the next thing you
want to do is mess it up with some lines
so you stick in how all of these
components relate to one another the
idea being that this will then show you
where some of the activities are not
supporting the rest of the app and help
you identify opportunities to improve
now that's all well and good but I
mentioned this was all about data didn't
know so what with what's missing here
and which will really rely on your
having a very robust analytics system is
to put in the proportion of users who
were successfully going from Step a to
step B which will then allow you to see
where the weak points are in your flow
for example there might be some
issues with return from notifications
and some issues with notification
permission you can draw a conclusion
there so this mapping of user flows
really helps everyone in your business
talk about the product in the same way
and understand how their activities
impact the overall that north start
metric once you've worked out where your
area for improvement is I mentioned
notifications was something in this
example then next step is to drill down
on what are the key key levers that will
impact that metric so in the case of
notifications for example we had average
users opted in we had average number of
notifications sent and for example the
click-through rate of those
notifications this is not rocket science
but just drawing it out helps everyone
to be clear on what the potential levers
you have are now I mentioned just need
to have a spreadsheet in here somewhere
so once you've mapped out that
subsection transfer it to a spreadsheet
link it all up together and you can run
scenario analysis to compare your
different competing ideas to see which
one will have the biggest impact on your
Northstar metric now to tell us more
about their experience because as I said
the Northstar metric seems pretty simple
but I think we know there's a lot more
complex thinking that that goes into it
I'd like to welcome on stage John
Butterfield a head of growth of one tap
so one of the things we did when we
first started making this product is
focusing on analytics and we track
everything user does within the app and
this is something that we are really
proud of but we'll see kind of how that
one unraveled while working with
Townsend so the first thing we did as
Tamsin showed you earlier was we created
this user flow this thing up here this
is about the 10th iteration of it the
first one had thousands and thousands of
different things in it and it was just a
cluster thing I won't say the word and
we don't it down to this and we actually
worked with the head of growth at Google
on this one as well and the thing he
really gave us as a key takeaway is
don't include everything from the app
just the key moments and the key
journeys and the first thing this did
for us actually was show that we have
some problems and this at the end that
weird mustardy call it bit where it's
essentially like an exit point the user
doesn't flirt the user journey doesn't
come all the way back around so this was
the first useful part of building
building this model so the next thing
was about the North Star metric and now
this is an interesting one because for
us it's pretty simple so our mission as
a company as you can see is to make
being being self-employed easier than
being employed and so if we want to make
this easier the best thing we can do is
quite simple there we go
ace collects transactions the more
transactions we collects for a user the
more we can provide value and it's all
about providing that value so
transactions per user is and is a really
easy one for us but then we break it
down per product so with one tap
receipts the obvious thing here is the
transaction in that is a receipt receipt
per user now the tricky part here and
the thing that really throws off was
what's more important users adding a lot
of receipts or a lot of users just
adding a few receipts so again you've
got to think about the value and the
value is them you know if they give us
more data we can then help them with
their taxes and do everything for them
essentially so it is all about receipts
per user and the more receipts the
better so then we put it into our growth
model as you saw is like this really
long document of all things the whole
equation of the growth model so I didn't
put all that in because it's just too
much and it's really boring but when we
first wrote that out it is about 16
pages of this document and he was crazy
so again
we took the idea of just dumbing it down
and making it something that anybody can
understand and the headline here was
receipts added per user and it's broken
down by the Mau divided by the receipt
submissions and then it's the receipt
submissions as you can see defined by
the different entry points and new and
returning users so what was interesting
in here as I said we're really proud of
the analytics and the tracking that we
put in with it within the app but while
we started working on this we suddenly
realized hang on we're not tracking this
this and this and these are all things
that provide value and make it easier
for us to deliver our Northstar metric
so suddenly it made us realized we've
got to go back and update our analytics
and things like that and with this
growth model one of the most interesting
things it did was that it made it easier
for us to explain to the CEO who I won't
bash in this session today because it's
that right there
I Nick its building as well actually
which is even worse so it made it so he
could see why the the mail comes from
and then the CFO could see worth all the
revenue comes from and products who's
also sitting there could see what what
essentially would work next to what
levers to pull to get the most amount of
value so then we put it into this
calculator this growth model spreadsheet
this is just the the first part of it
but again you can see here with the
starting values essentially what happens
over ten days and this is just the high
level it goes further into detail as you
go into it but again was boring to show
you nobody really wants to see that but
the best thing is it's all it's a
predictor and this an in this calculator
the spreadsheet we actually renamed it
as a calculator that's why I keep
calling you that because to be honest
nobody really cares about spreadsheets
especially myself calculator because it
helps us predict what we can do so
absolutely while bringing in the
equation from the previous one I'm gonna
go back that one so once we had this
equation and we put it into the
spreadsheet we suddenly started
questioning where the value was as well
so there was a lot of things we put into
the original model that suddenly just
made no sense so we really it really
gave us a good lesson on how what we
should be tracking and why so it was
really useful all right and then the
next part these what the model actually
gave us so the first thing is it gave us
clarity about what it would cross all
departments about what it is we're doing
so like the CEO Nick no longer had SIL I
asked about why the mal was coming from
and how we could increase it clear as
day in this model and then products
didn't have to like necessarily ask what
are we gonna do next what's priority is
all based on this and the CFO knew that
by increasing revenue we increase
retention so they could see from the
growth model as well essentially what is
happening next
although the CFO dis just still
sometimes go very Jerry Maguire and show
me the money but that's yeah it's not
too bad
and then the resource is the big thing
we realized is that because we're a seat
up and we do a lot with finances we
should be putting a lot of priority into
accountants right and that's something
we've not really done too much of in the
past so it's a huge wake up call that is
a huge lever there that if we put more
effort into that we could essentially
get lots more users a lot easier and
help them keep retained now that also
helped with hires so one of the problems
you have that we certainly have is going
trigger-happy on glass door and just
hiring the wrong people at the wrong
time so this really helps with knowing
who you should hire purpura kind of
problem you have at the time and what
levers you want to pull so for us it was
partner channels so that was really good
and that's it
that's it Thank You Tamsin oh wait on I
think mine's working
thank you John that was fantastic
hopefully that give you some gave you
some really good insights into I guess
one model or one way of working oh thank
you yes what was I gonna click with my
fingers one one way of working to help
you prioritize and bring the company
together
now one thing you may have picked up on
apart for the fact that their CEOs in
the audience was that the model really
helped them help John to communicate why
they were doing certain things with
product marketing CEO and all the other
teams so let me ask you a question how
many people in the audience today do
prioritization or experimentation by
them just by themselves without working
with anyone else okay a few people how
many of you do this in a team just one
team a lot more okay if you're not doing
it across your company you can do better
in a very positive way so top developers
I've spoken to ensure that there's
cross-functional representation when
they do this kind of prioritization so
that everyone's on board and aligned
towards that common goal whether you
call it the North Star metric or
anything else you like to choose and
culture is critical to this you need to
have an acceptance of risk and return
and to take us through their approach
more on the riskier side I'd like to
invite on the stage
Christina knodel's head of product for
memorize
thank you good afternoon everyone I'm so
happy to be here and I know that we are
running out of time shorten everyone is
quite excited to get to the longer
networking break I think my talk is
going to be brief I have to apologize I
should be doing this in German working
in a language learning gap but English
is not my first language so maybe this
is an excuse for this time memorize is a
favorite language learning app for about
25 million people it's very vibrant and
lifelike way to become confident in
using a foreign language in any country
or any situation people experience and
we have a record number of over 200
language pairs that people can learn and
hopefully eventually speak and the next
few minutes I will be sharing some some
insights of how we do product
prioritization and also manage our CEO
memorize has had a very unique journey
so far so we've been super lucky with
having one of the most creative and
experimental CEOs out there it has its
upsides which means that it's a great
inspiration and it injects a lot of
creative thinking and and
experimentalism to the rest of the team
the downside is that it kind of sets the
slightly different challenge for for
product people and product team to
manage the whole thing and manage all
these creative ideas coming out of the
brains like that and as an example about
two years ago I got a text message from
Ed our CEO on Sunday morning
saying that good morning Christina I'm
in Scotland
I bought a double-decker bus
I'm going to find a repairman who is
going to fix it a driver and the film
crew and the bus is going to tour the
rest of the Europe filming videos of
native speakers saying phrases and
sentences in all these different
languages that are spoken in these
European countries so it was quite a
unique experience to get a message like
that and what happened was that we we
had to sort of come up ways how to
handle these kind of creative ideas and
and very often slightly crazy ideas and
how to turn them into successful
features for our product so what
happened was we had to come up with a
way how to filter and how to assess and
measure such crazy ideas that not just
the CEOs but also everyone in the team
can come up with and we kind of felt
like spreadsheets and and different
models and frameworks and systems and
processes are maybe too harsh for
filtering out some genius pieces of
creative glimpses and we ended up having
and coming up with six criteria for how
to filter out useful ideas out of like
generic nonsense and the six criteria
that we came up with was every single
idea has to be iterable which means that
we should start small we should take
every feature as an MVP and then iterate
if it is successful we think that the
the idea has to have an immediate impact
so as soon as we roll out the feature
and and launch it for our users we do
want to see some kind of a fail behavior
change or or some change in metrics it
has to have a lasting effect which means
that one-trick ponies do not quite work
for us we do want to build features that
have an impact on on language learners
for an extended period of time not just
for the first five minutes or or the
first day everything has to be merged
obviously and it has to have a power of
localization which I think for a
language learning app is maybe a unique
but user base for almost any up in the
out there is very global so it's good to
benefit from from making sure that it
works in every single language for every
culture for right-to-left and
left-to-right languages and finally
obviously it all has to fit into a
coherent product so even the craziest
ideas just have to fit in somewhere and
make sense and we went even deeper so in
order to keep this kind of creative and
experimental mindset in the company and
an in every single team we divided our
product development lifecycle into three
stages the first one being the discovery
stage where we prototype we sketch we
design withdraw we use the dust the idea
we build something that we can sort of
get random people from the street to
test it out in the memorize members case
the discovery phase included sending the
bus to a mini trip to Oxford to fill in
the videos in English first to see
whether like this makes any sense or not
before touring the rest of the Europe
and after sort of doing the dry runs and
and testing these ideas out we define it
in a fairly detailed spec with with all
the functionality described everything
all the sketches all the designs thrown
out we do involve data team in this
stage of the process quite heavily
because they we have to make sure that
we we built the feature for the right
user for the right use case we we track
and implement the the data points in a
correct way so it's super important that
that the data people are involved in the
process once everything is ready and set
up the development teams take over
and actually start building the features
because everyone has been quite nicely
involved in in the discovery and in the
definition phase it's fairly easy for
the developers to understand why we're
building things and and how exactly they
need to be built from the product
perspective a super key thing to keep in
mind is that even with the most
sophisticated systems and and processes
in place it even happens for the most
experienced product managers that you
sometimes forget to switch on the
feature and experiment when it goes out
so that the users will actually see it
what you've built and once everything is
nicely set up and the new version of the
of the app is out and now it's time to
take a photo of this as well it's the
it's the joyful moment of watching her
when and how the results come in we are
organized as well so it's not like we're
all over the place with crazy ideas we
have a standard set of metrics standard
car graphs for every single experiment a
B test feature that goes out and sort of
the day after the release it's like
refreshing this Bailey page all the time
which is the sort of reasonable and
sensible way to to see how the feature
and the new idea has performed in our
team's case it's also the joy and fun of
seeing the results coming in and and
learning whether we build something
super successful that people enjoy or or
whether we need to go back to the
whiteboard and and sort of sketch and
start thinking again so I think your
vision is quite popular in Germany so
it's almost like watching the results
come in votes coming in and and then
seeing like whether we've on a winning
case a losing case so hopefully this has
given you a few ideas how to do product
prioritization without spreadsheets as
well and and also manage the crazy ideas
coming from your CEO thank you